scribe
Betty Ford in one word,
it would be candid.
She spoke her mind.
I think the American public
really liked her for that.
(upbeat music)
From an early age,
Betty Ford wanted
to be a dancer.
- She studied
dance, modern dance,
hoping, in fact, to one day
become a professional dancer.
- She moved to New
York City so that
she could dance in Martha
Graham's dance troupe.
Betty Ford performed
at Carnegie Hall,
but her mother
eventually convinced her
to move back to Grand
Rapids and settle down.
Betty met Gerald Ford while he
was campaigning for Congress.
- They did get
married just two weeks
before he was sworn into office.
So, she was involved
in politics from
the very, very beginning.
Betty Ford is the
only First Lady
whose husband was not
elected Vice President
or President.
- She was thrust in
the position after
Watergate toppled Richard Nixon.
The next month they
discovered a lump
in her right breast.
Two days after that,
that breast was removed.
Betty Ford was lying
in a hospital room,
and she said she got
to thinking about
the power of the woman
in the White House.
The power to do good
in this position.
- This was a time when
breast cancer was
just not talked about.
It was considered embarrassing.
Mammography was
a new technology.
- So for Mrs. Ford to
speak openly about her
breast cancer was startling,
stunning, amazing.
She encouraged women
to go have mammograms,
and she pushed forward
breast cancer research
and lifted the stigma.
It was a remarkable
thing that she did,
remarkably brave.
- I think this did
more to impact America
than anything any
First Lady ever did.
Just because of the
number of lives she saved.
Betty Ford's chief
cause in the White House
the Equal Rights Amendment.
When she got to the White House,
ERA ratification was
pretty much stalled.
So Betty Ford
spent a lot of time
lobbying for the ERA.
She did this in public and
she did it behind the scenes.
Betty Ford also
tried to get a woman
appointed to the Cabinet
and to the Supreme Court.
She said that she was
employing all means necessary,
including pillow talk
at the end of the day
when she thought her husband
was the most vulnerable.
- Betty Ford is probably
best known for the
stigma that she took
away from alcoholism.
She openly admitted
about her own alcoholism.
Her father and brother
were also alcoholics.
- In the 1960s, she
had a pinched nerve and
was treated for this chronic
pain with painkillers.
- That was really the
beginning of her struggle
with drugs and alcohol.
- She went to a rehab
that was predominantly
designed for men.
And she said women's issues,
particularly regarding
alcoholism, and
women's issues in general,
were very different than men's.
- She eventually will
create the Betty Ford Center
for treating addiction
issues and will
stipulate that 50% of the
beds would be for women.
Her work for women
throughout her time as
First Lady would continue into
this new stage of her life.